[Music]
roshan the camel is a bit of a celebrity
here
whenever he clops through children know
he's bringing some exciting tales to
their village
books to help them with their reading at
first i tried to read the books myself
but if i do not understand anything i
ask the teacher
i prefer picture books because when i
look at the pictures and the photographs
i can understand the story better
the camel library began moving in august
roshan takes books to four villages in
the manned region
of pakistan's southern baluchistan
province which has the lowest literacy
rate in the country
at just 40 percent rahima jalal started
the project with the help of ngos
in addition to keeping children busy
she's also helping their parents
when the coronavirus spread the entire
region all the schools were closed there
was an atmosphere of depression
for old and young alike there's no
entertainment for the children at all in
the region where i live
the only activity for the children is to
go to school and then go back home
murad ali owns the camel and used it to
carry firewood through remote and rugged
areas to market that was before he was
approached with a better offer
i was asked if i would like to carry
books on my camel i was surprised
and thought how can i carry books on my
camel but now i carry them to four
villages and the children love it
i'm also very happy so are people in the
villages so it's an ongoing thing
and i'm happy to do it
most of the budget around 120 dollars a
month goes to employ the camel
those behind the project plan to expand
to more villages once they find support
but for now the kids have picked the
books of their choice and say goodbye
until next time
andrew chappelle al jazeera